[Music]
the mic oh right underneath the camera I
haven't done one of these in a minute oh
wow matching wallpapers Oh what if I can
that's awesome hey what's up guys I'm
kitty HD here you guys just heard that
intro music shout out to 20 Syl he is
doing 36 new songs or sharing 36 new
songs in 36 days that was one of them
they've all been pretty sick there on
his YouTube channel so I'll link it
below check him out one of the most
underrated nicest guys and music good
stuff so here we are I'm taking a page
out of Peter MacKinnon's playbook which
was just his tweet last night that you
can do a Q a while still practicing
social distancing so that's what I'm
gonna do the studio is empty here I'll
take a video here we see an empty mkbhd
studio in 8k on the galaxy s 20 Ultra
that's what you guys look like look at
that focus so I made the choice that at
least for the foreseeable future will
stay on the safe side and make sure no
one has to travel to get to the studio
so I'm here solo but I asked on Twitter
what you guys wanted to know and it's
time for Q&A also I'm just realizing
that tagging him in my tweet my Q&A
tweet means all of you thousands of
questions that are responses to it also
got sent to him sorry about that
Peter maybe he'll use some of your
questions for his video who knows anyway
I just want to say I know I haven't
spoken up a lot about the virus and all
the turmoil that is surrounded it in the
world mainly because I'm not an expert
I'm not a healthcare professional or a
doctor so I'm getting all my information
from others as you should be you
shouldn't get information from me so I'm
in the u.s. I'm listening to the CDC I'm
listening to trusted experts but if I
can echo their best advice wash your
hands sanitize them stay socially
distanced it's the smart thing to do to
try to flatten the curb and prevent the
spread of the virus I think I'll leave
any links in the description that may be
helpful to those of you who are just
wondering about it but generally be
responsible
take care of yourself to take care of
others so that being said let's see if
you guys have any good questions on
Twitter oh yeah okay right off the bat
did you get any threats from Escobar Inc
no I haven't gotten any communication
from them at all which is probably the
story with a lot of people now there was
a quick update briefly their website was
down and a lot of people were sending it
to me the night after I made my video
screenshots of it I tried going to their
website it was also down but then like a
half a day later it came back and it
looks like they're still taking orders
so if you were considering ordering one
don't obviously oh okay
interesting what are your total watch
hours from your viewers I think I can
just look that up actually so the number
is seven point four built billion seven
point four billion minutes in the last
twelve years of videos hey Google what's
seven point four billion minutes in
hours one point two three three times
ten to the eight hours hey Google what's
seven point four billion minutes in days
seven billion four hundred million
minutes is equal to five point one three
nine times ten to the six days hey
Google what's seven point four billion
minutes in years here's a summary from
the website research maniacs calm let's
start with how you would write seven
point four billion with numbers only huh
one seven billion four hundred million
and this is how you would write seven
point four billion with letters only -
hey Siri million for what seven point
four billion years fourteen thousand and
sixty nine point eight years nice okay
what do you most want from the new
iPhones this year for me it's night mode
is a super cool feature to have on your
phone cool uh yeah I think there's just
a couple of main things I want out of I
phone twelve for 2020 number one it's
got to be higher frustrate display I'm
hoping for 120 Hertz this is something
that you know this is gonna be an
expensive phone when it comes out and if
you spend this much money on your phone
having high refresh rate seems like
mandatory so 120 Hertz screen then - I
would love to have USB type-c
while I know it's not the most likely
thing to happen I would really love to
get rid of some of my last non USB
type-c
chargers and maybe come with a fast
charger in the box and then three just
an overall generally updated design get
rid of this huge notch about the front
while I know it's housing a bunch of the
face ID sensors actually that ties into
the other thing I would change which is
adding touch ID back I think Apple tends
to be that company that waits to do
something correctly instead of being
first on the bandwagon and we've got a
bunch of under glass fingerprint sensors
now so I would love to see them do just
a giant bottom third of the screen
huge thumb press and that just reads
your fingerprint touch ID is back on
these phones and they you can get rid of
the huge knotch so new design touch ID
under the glass USB type-c and just a
generally much better screen okay so
which selfie camera do you think in a
smartphone is most practical they have a
1 + 7 Pro at the pop-up camera and they
want to know my stance on cutouts
notches and pop-up cameras so I would
almost make that like a tier list so you
got you have a through F or whatever and
F is like not having one but D tier for
me honestly is like if you have a thick
bezel which in 2020 is not a good look
or if you just have like a giant notch
and no real reason for a giant notch and
C tier would be like a reasonable notch
or you know the teardrop notches that
that could be in C tier then B tier is
your hole punch cut outs so the small
ones you know which you got on like
galaxy s 20 whether it's in the corner
or the center not a huge deal for me I
think I like it more in the center but
generally they take up the least amount
of space and they don't interrupt the
content as much so I'll say a tier is
the hole punch cut out but my other hot
take that I shared on Twitter before was
I really like pop-up cameras as an 80 or
selfie camera the main biggest possible
downside for it would be it's a moving
part but we haven't really seen anyone
reached that moving part limit yet which
is great and then possibly less
waterproofing but even some of the
phones with pop-up cameras have a little
seal around the bottom that dramatically
improves water resistance so it's not
the end of the world for water and dust
if you have a pop-up camera
there's all the benefits you get a full
screen display you don't have a selfie
camera when you don't need it it pops up
fast enough to do face unlock if you
want to do that but you probably don't
have to and best of all when it's
retracted inside your device it's being
blocked so you can't have someone hack
into and using your front-facing camera
long you don't need them using it so a
little security advantage too so a tear
for me is the pop-up cameras and the
punch outs and if we have like a future
possible s tear that would of course be
getting the selfie camera behind the
glass invisible so it's always available
but never interrupting the content but
we don't really have those yet maybe
that's something we could see in the
next iPhone if the tech is ready but
that's the question is would they be
would they be first to some tech like
that probably not we'll probably see it
on the way to the next next iPhone
all right the schedule tweeted Brownlee
just check out this just check this out
and it's a the TCL rollable phone
concept okay so I've had my eye on this
and I've thought about it a lot since we
first saw it for those who don't know
TCL in New York City not too long ago I
wish I got to be there but they showed a
bunch of concept foldable smartphone
modular designs just cuz they can so
while there were a lot of working phones
technically there as far as I know none
of these were actually slated to come
out as real phones but there was
everything from this this triple folding
display that makes like a W shape and
you can fold it up like a xylophone and
it's got three panes when it's open just
wild stuff like that
TCL figured they just make a bunch of
them and be first to it and if they get
good response maybe it'll make him later
but the one that really caught my eye
and we talked about this on the wave
form podcast was this rollable like
scroll like display so and this one
wasn't even a real this working screen
it was just paper like a fake screen on
top but the idea was still there that
you could have a regular-sized
smartphone with a full size display
looking totally normal that you use on a
regular basis and when you want to
expand it to a bigger screen you just
pull it out and from behind this extra
screen appears and now you have this
larger display that you just peeled out
like a scroll actually now that I think
about it it was really difficult to
explain on the podcast but seeing it and
some demos of it really got the gears
turning like maybe foldable isn't the
only way to use these flexible displays
to put a bigger screen in a smaller form
factor this whole rolling thing I don't
know if it's not possible yet with a
screen on it or if it would just damage
the screen too much but I don't know I
would like to see an actual working
device do that so this really got the
gears turning because of course for me
the whole point of having these big
flexible screens is hey big screen small
pocket fold it up it fits that's that's
the general point so the triple screen
one doesn't really make as much sense to
me just because that's still gonna be a
huge thick boy phone when you try to
fold it and put it in your pocket it
looks cool but it's also not super
useful
that's form over function but this
rollable screen one looked interesting
and I'll pass actually to you guys in
the comments section would you rather
have a rollable display or a foldable
display just on what you've seen on that
foldable display concept alright someone
asked how is the new studio coming along
also advice for an upcoming tech
youtuber cheers yeah
the studio is coming along great I
posted a couple updates on Twitter and
Instagram so far if you want to check
those out I would go shoot down there
now if I wasn't trying specifically to
be social distancing responsibly we're
gonna have some blackout shades in there
and a lot of blinds we're gonna have
some new light switches we're gonna have
fiber internet in there gigabit internet
that's pretty sick and I just acoustic
treatment is the number one thing for us
to worry about for the entire space so
slowly but surely right here's a here's
a potential sad one or great one
opinions on the upcoming Canon EOS r5
and would you purchase it I want to just
say yes so a lot of us camera nerds been
following us but if you haven't there
are rumors and partially confirmed
rumors now that Canon is working on a
new eos are called the r5 it's gonna be
a pro level camera it's gonna have 8k
video with advanced autofocus and it's
gonna have all these pro features and be
an amazing video camera and that's about
all they've told us is that that's what
they're working on matter of fact Peter
MacKinnon's probably seen more of this
than anyone he's held one and talked to
Canada about it but generally I want to
be excited about it
but I also know Canon if you followed
canons stuff you know there's always a
catch there's always a great camera all
the great specs but this horrible thing
like I have a Canon EOS our loved that
camera for a lot of stuff great video
quality but huge crowd and this is
happen with other cameras the 1d x mark
3 is awesome but proprietary memory
cards this happens a lot I'm nervous
about what that hitch is gonna be for
the EOS r5 is it gonna be $20,000 or is
it gonna be record limit at 8k or
overheating problems or a crop or
autofocus what is what is it gonna be so
I'm hesitant to get excited about it but
kind of like the red comodo we don't
really know that much about it so I'll
keep my fingers crossed all right I'm
gonna end it with actually I had some
questions for you guys that I pulled you
on on Twitter two things one was just
straight up how many of you guys have a
case on your phone you might have seen
this in one of the last videos if I was
guessing I would have said something
maybe a little over fifty fifty I know
cases are popular but surely not
everyone has a case right but just of
this audience 80% of you have a case on
your phone which means in the rest of
the world
I'm sure it's even higher so that was
pretty interesting and then the other
question I asked you guys was what is
your phone volume set to is it volume on
silent or vibrate and I literally never
have my volume on as far as my ringtone
I don't even know if my ringtone sounds
like most of the time and so far the
poll is running right now on Twitter but
so far vibrate is winning but that could
change as the rest of the votes fill in
but I just I don't know I like learning
about these behaviors that I sort of
take for granted and then actually ask
you guys about and figure out the answer
is totally wild like why did 25 percent
you have your volume on all the time why
I don't get it
what why is it always on so anyway
that's been it thank you for the Q&A
hopefully you guys are staying safe out
there and by out there I mean in there
because you're staying home and yeah I
guess let's just let's just let these
internet videos be our little safe haven
for entertainment while we're you know
self quarantine basically and keeping
the world safe thanks for watching catch
she has the next one
pace